thank you
and it's great to have a bunch of people
out in the audience who know more about
this topic than i do that always makes
me feel good
uh so i'm sure you know i i'm going to
kind of give like a high level
uh philosophical talk about what we're
doing and and
why we're doing it and uh i'm i'm going
to let some of these people out in the
audience ask me questions that i can't
answer about
how we did it um but
anyways uh what i'm going to talk about
is dynamic code optimization which is
our uh well how we're referring to
binary translation
and in nvidia's denver processor uh
we're sort of referring to it as a
techno you know that's our technological
amalgam of
our secret sauce plus things that have
been done
uh many times in the past uh over many
many years as a few people have
uh reminded me uh prior to the talk so
um anyways i just want to say thanks to
you know this this talk i we couldn't be
giving it without the efforts of a
a lot of people at nvidia i'm just the
person up in front
so uh last year um
daryl boggs uh talked about denver
integra k1 uh it is
it was the the first 64-bit uh
arm v8 chip that ran android apple beat
everyone else to the punch with
v8 and 64-bit a few months before
but we were the first chip to run
android and we in that chip we had two
two denver cpus so
uh just just to wind back to that time
nvidia released two separate chips
within a few months they were very very
closely related
the only thing that was different about
them was the
cpu complex in one of them
we had quad a15s and it was a 32-bit
machine
and uh in the other we had two denver's
uh denver is you know 64-bit uh
a15s and uh out-of-order three-way super
three-way out-of-order machine denver's
a seven-way super scalar
uh in order uh our clock frequency is
2.5 gigahertz versus the 2.3
and in the a15 and uh we have some
considerably
bigger caches uh
which uh you know and the yielded
performance out of denver is is
considerably higher than than out of a15
on a
on a single threaded uh for single
thread benchmarks
for multi-core there are some places
where uh quad a15s is
is faster than denver but for the most
part
uh we are faster so the value
proposition there was to have a very
high performance uh
v8 processor nobody had v8
other than apple before us it's very
energy efficient
which allows you know all arm chips are
well not all but many arm chips are in
uh thermally constrained environments
you have batteries
uh power efficiency is is a big deal
that's a big deal for more and more of
computing these days and
um you know cpu really
in an soc context uh is
is especially the company like nvidia is
seen as a little bit of a tax that they
don't want to pay
we're a company that designs graphics
processors
the graphics complex can dissipate a lot
more heat
than uh and and
use a lot more electricity than the cpu
can and
they really want as much of that back as
they can get so
having an energy efficient arm that
still gets the work done is is important
and
the other thing that denver gave that we
didn't think was well addressed by
existing arm chips was that we were able
to execute
more of the high performance
pc style applications because of our
high single threaded
capability
so this is sort of the uh
high-level block diagram of denver uh
you can see we we have you know just
sort of walk through the pipeline
you have an instruction fetch unit which
is fetching out of the eye cache
it can be fetching either microcode or
arm instructions if it's in the arm
instruction mode
those instructions are being fed into a
hardware decoder which does a very
simple one to two instruction
translation
of those instructions into a
naive native microcode implementation of
those instructions
and then and then the results are fed
down into the scheduler and executed on
the seven wide machine
so obviously if you're just taking in
one to two arm instructions at a time
and
playing them on this seven wide machine
you're probably idle most of the time
and so uh that's where dynamic code
optimization comes in
it's how we uh it's it's the technology
we use
to sort of figure out how to use this
large wide execution resource that we
have
so some of the features of denver that
may or may not be familiar to all of you
we have a skewed pipeline i'll talk a
little bit more about that
in in the next slide we have
hardware prefetcher uh we
have run ahead so on cache misses we can
get some useful work done
under the cache miss uh and that is
sort of one of the that's that's been an
idea that's been kicking around for a
while
in in-order machines i think we've made
it work and made it yield performance
uh and we have transactional memory and
i know that uh
intel and powerpc and a lot of other
people have exposed transactional memory
at the iso level
uh we do it under the covers and use
that to accelerate
our uh
accelerate code that runs on the
processor
so i talked a little bit about pipeline
sku um
this is kind of a i just wanted to
briefly talk about it because it's
something that surprised some people
who've come into our project from other
other places a traditional critique
of wide in-order machines is that it's
really hard to schedule onto them
particularly if you have limited
scheduling regions
you'll tend to have a bunch of loads up
front
you'll have to wait a while in order to
be able to use the results from those
loads
and control flow can become sort of
problematic in terms of the scheduling
um
what we do in denver is we have these
wide superscalar ops we call them or
wide super scalar we call them bundles
which are a collection of ops that come
in
you can think of them as entering the
machine at the same time
but depending upon the kind of operation
they are they execute at different times
in the processor pipeline
and we have bypassing between the
different units that allows them to be
the results to be used later in in sort
of useful ways so
uh what i've diagrammed here is sort of
what i think of as the big
big deal bypasses from loads you can
bypass
to the arithmetic units from the
arithmetic
units you can bypass back out to stores
or you can bypass predicate results into
our branch unit
so what that leads to is bundles that
look a little bit like this
i've tried to use some color coding to
help out with this
but what you can see in this is we have
a load
where the result is being used to feed
an ad and then the result of the ad is
being fed back out to a store uh
we're taking a com we're doing a compare
on the
value that we loaded and then we're
branching based on the result of that
compare
so what you can see is it's not
immediately obvious until you start
looking at larger
windows of instructions but if you're
taking
arm operations and trying to map them
into
wide bundles that allows you to have a
really dense
you know to to really densely pack those
sort of all the way through despite
having quite a bit of control flow
transfer back and forth
so uh you might think that that would
extend
our uh branch penalties uh
you know having you know that we've
maybe delayed things
uh out too far and that we have you know
a bunch of things coming in they're not
executing as soon as they could and then
we're
delaying the commit of their results
until some later time
and thus far we're not seeing it we have
a lower branch mispredict penalty
than a15 i haven't looked at
a 57 lately but i'm pretty sure it's
about the same
so in terms of yielded performance this
is just
denver i tried to go and update the
slides that daryl gave
versus some of the competition we're
looking in a
5 watt form factor so there the intel
desktops are really limited to they have
a 1.4 gigahertz skew that we think
might fit into something like that i'm
actually not sure whether they need a
fan
in that sku or not um
comparing against apple a8 and a few
others which
are considerably lower performance i'd
say
so i'm not a big fan of benchmarks
but what you can see is denver is is
really good at moving
data in and out of memory which we think
is is very important it's been a
weakness
of a lot of processors out there uh
and we we really get desktop
well not desktop but we get performance
equivalent to some of these
other processors squeezed into the kinds
of you know and and even
much better than traditional mobile
processors squeezed into those kinds of
form factors
so that's kind of the high level
overview of denver
um by the way people can interrupt me if
there's
i'm used to these talks being a little
bit more interactive
but uh please
please go ahead and interrupt me if
there's anything yes
uh i think our base our baseline here is
the k132
so we were just comparing against the
a15
competition so a57
i think on a lot of these
is per clock is it 10 or
10 or more percent faster i think than
that
uh for these benchmarks uh you're
generally
so this is 2.5 gigahertz for spec
you would be pretty close to the thermal
limits
in with with denver but i don't think
you'd necessarily be
think you'd necessarily be thermally
throttled there
um for a lot of the other ones they're
they're over quickly enough that it's
all about edp rather than tdp
so um oh sorry uh
edp in this context is uh electrical
dissipation of the power regulator and
tdp
would be the sustained
power that you can run over run at until
you know your heat sink
runs out of gas or
people get burned or something like that
so so
dco we say that's optimized once uh used
many times as the
philosophy uh we think that's a huge
savings in terms of
uh you know efficiency of
microarchitectures
and you know kind of try to get into why
that's the case
so uh this this is sort of how i think
of you know to
just to sort of wind up wind back uh i
think when all of you went and took your
first computer architecture class you're
probably
presented with a view that is a little
bit like this uh which is
um or at least i i had this
impression when i sort of came when i
came into industry and it was a
different time back then
as it always is
so you have software which is going to
run
on one device so of course it's going to
be compiled with the optimal set of
compiler flags
that compiler is going to figure out
everything there is to know about that
piece of software and
and optimally express it in terms of an
isa which was
chosen by uh
i don't know a a committee of experts
and uh was not only write
the right exact right set of
instructions 20 years ago but
it was the exact right set of
instructions today and
at every midpoint in between i don't
know how they did that but
it's incredible uh and then
your hardware so you're a hardware
designer you want to go and design
something that people are going to sell
well given those two things
your job's easy right you just pick the
right
you know whatever the the right
expression of of that iso and your
hardware is
and and you're good to go um
you don't have any legacy to think about
you don't have any corner cases
it's all just you know they were
thinking about you when it when it came
time to to design
hardware so
i my view is a little bit different uh
or
or perhaps a more cynical view of things
after you've been around a while is as
well
most software isn't designed for you
it's it's junk you have no idea why
people run it but
but they do it
if it is optimized for something it's
probably optimized for your competition
because they came in and paid somebody
to do that
so it uses all the all the things that
run well on their hardware and none of
the things that run well on yours
your isa has 20 years of decisions that
went into it and some of them were good
decisions at the time and some of them
weren't
uh unfortunately you have to implement
all of them as a hardware guy
and so what you end up with is
hardware that is just overbuilt in a lot
of ways
you've designed you really don't know
what's going to come
in to you as a hardware designer and
your past experiences
boy you get all these things that make
no sense and and people ask them ask you
to make them run fast anyways
so what are you going to do you're just
going to build more and lay down more
and more gates until you account for
all of those cases that you didn't get
last time
and and the result as a user is that
you're paying a tax
you're paying for a lot of hardware guys
to design a lot of hardware that
maybe you don't really care that much
about but but they had to do it because
of
one reason or another they had to lay
down those gates to make something
or other run fast or they're too afraid
to pull them out
so just to
to wind back a little bit so what what
are what is hardware good at and what is
software good at you know what what
should we
how should we be thinking about it uh
given
given that we do sort of live in the
real world well
i think hardware is good at really fast
decisions
that are made based on simple inputs
uh and and where the output itself is
also
fairly simple to do do i have this data
in my cache yes or no should i take this
branch yes or no
those are those are things that hardware
is is usually
reasonably good at doing um
but the flexibility of hardware is low
uh it costs costs you something to build
it
and and to run it and it takes you a
long time to fix it
if you did something wrong
software is is much better at very
complex
decisions involving lots and lots of
inputs
and it's very flexible you can get it
wrong
you can change it later
and and you can do that in a reasonably
short period of time
so when it comes to performance of your
micro architecture
and and what should run on your micro
architecture
you would want to push as many of these
decisions that can be made
in made one time with some complex
inputs
and have that you know if that
decision's
right most of the time you would like to
move all those decisions
into software and have the software
express express
that decision to the hardware in a way
that the hardware is able to
quickly recognize and and do the right
thing about
so the problem is in the traditional
software stack
you have to rewrite the world in order
to do that you have to go and find write
that perfect compiler
you have to compile everything uh then
you have to find every jit that's out
there and you have to
rewrite that jet uh you know
then you have to find all the all the
other languages i mean there's there's
just hundreds and millions or
of lines of code even in fairly
uh constrained systems like android that
you would have to go out and change
there are binaries that you'd have to
recompile that uh
probably the person who owns that binary
is no longer supporting it but people
run it anyways
uh so it's it's a really difficult
problem and and what i would say is it's
inevitable that you're going to fail at
that
trying to solve that and so
the result of failing to solve that
problem is that is that hardware has
this dusty deck problem that just builds
up every year
in a in a successful ecosystem and
you as a user are are paying power
area dollars for people to try to solve
that in hardware
so the approach we took with uh
dco and this is uh very similar to the
uh you know again this is sort of our
our brand name for for
what other people call dynamic uh binary
translation in the past
is that we we still have that realistic
view of software that it's largely
optimized for other products
we're going to go out and find things
that
need to be optimized for our
architecture and we're going to make
sure those get optimized but we know
that's
just a very small subset of what's out
there
uh we know that the isa because it's
successful we chose something successful
because it's
you know you want to do that you want to
have the software ecosystem
but we're not necessarily going to
design the hardware for that
the hardware is going to be designed for
this intermediate software layer that's
the
essentially the single point of contact
for all performance and power issues
that the hardware might encounter and
what that software is going to do is in
in cases where
uh it it's going to take in this
unoptimized software and it's going to
try to map it very efficiently onto the
architecture
and it's going to make sure that what it
creates is observably equivalent
to what the input was so it will uh
it will change no architectural register
in any way that that
is observably different it will leave
the memory subsystem
exactly as the memory subsystem is
expected to be after executing some
some region of code but it will
efficiently map work onto
onto the underlying hardware and it will
uh you know it will aggressively remove
anything that it
seems to be as not required
so now as a hardware designer your job's
a little bit easier
uh you're gonna you have one set of
software people to talk about
talk to about what your underlying
microcode format should be
you're going to work with them you're
going to figure out what
the promises are that they can make
about the input incoming code that runs
on your hardware
and and what promises you can provide to
them and then
uh you know in collaboration you're
going to design a piece of hardware that
you think is the best map
onto today's technology so
it kind of puts control of the micro
architecture
i i think a little bit back into the
uh you know a little bit back towards
the
the more idealized view of the world
where you're making decisions that you
think are rational as opposed
to decisions that are based on some sort
of fear about what you might see
so this is the dusty deck uh description
does that apply
to phones well so let me ask you a
question
uh have you ever bought a phone uh
that runs android that okay well
that's a different question but have any
of you bought
android phones which didn't have
floating point units
what's the default calling convention on
android for arch 32
it's soft floating point so all of your
floating point arguments get passed
through the integer register file
yeah it's insane and it can't change
and all those apps are all out there
yeah i mean there's nothing you can do
about it you can point it out and people
will say yes that
that's how it works uh you know
somebody probably 10 years ago forgot to
split the compiler compiler flag it's
never going to change
i i think that's gonna it's good news
for arch 64 because that's going to
drive people to
this 64-bit calling convention but
it's it's dusty deck it's here it's in
your phone
uh there's there's plenty more than that
out there
uh so that's the direct decision
yeah yeah i mean you you build
if you build an ecosystem of some sort
you're going to make mistakes along the
way
yeah could this be
lethargy in the ecosystem
well i mean you could say it's lethargy
but
uh what what's the option right you
would
you would have to ship all of your
libraries
compiled both ways which is
is not impossible to do but uh
then then people will start to complain
about you know
i have to have all these gigabytes of
library files twice
why they're gigabytes of library files
that's another thing but you know
so if if you go with this
technique to your micro architecture
you're you're simplifying a lot of
things for your hardware designers
and and i just gave a you know a list of
things that i
i think that you can uh
have software do you know software that
is more
mic architecturally aware do and
um you know i don't think there's
anything profound about this list
the real list is is considerably longer
so in denver
we should just walk through how we do
dynamic code optimization
how how your program runs when it's on a
denver processor
so at the start of time we're fetching
instructions
arm instructions out of arm space we're
decoding them onto this hardware decoder
one or two times one or two instructions
at a time
we are recording branch profile
information as we do that
at some point after we've executed some
number of these
we are going to take a micro interrupt
which is going to run on another core
uh we hope an optimization
thread which is going to go and look at
this profile data
and is going to figure out what
instructions you were executing what the
branch profiles were and it's going to
figure out
how to more efficiently represent the
execution of those instructions
on the underlying denver hardware
so it's going to do a lot of things
uh i've just given a long list of
uh compiler things that we do there's
there's plenty more
uh if you have questions you can ping
john at some point but
we probably can't answer
so at some point you're going to
at some point this optimizer is going to
be done it's going to emit an
optimized microcode region that
that corresponds to the original arm
bytes
and in the future when you
see execution at the entry point to that
sequence of arm bytes you are going to
jump directly to
the uh corresponding microcode region
that was generated
how do you know when to jump is there
hardware or do you patch the software
uh there is hardware support
uh i think we've filed patents so
it's out there i'm sure but uh uh
i don't think we're terribly specific
about what we've done
but i mean it's not
how many ways can you do lookups not
very many right
so especially in hardware
um so uh we're going to continue that
process
for uh the rest of the program whatever
the program may be
or at least the hot regions of the
program uh in a perfect world where
uh things are not enormous we're
eventually going to
end up with a number of microcode
regions which all
directly link to each other when you
execute you'll
you know you may execute a few
instructions in the hardware decoder you
will jump
off into the microcode regions and
hopefully you'll spend a very
good long time in microcode and not in
the hardware decoder
so this was an example that daryl gave
at hot chips it's just a
look at what our overhead and hardware
decoder looks like
over time in crafty so
in here the the green green bar
is optimized translation execution
which you can see sort of starts you
know maybe starts at 40 percent
uh early on in the profile and then
quickly jumps to about 100 percent
uh we have the overhead as the little
red bar
there and um the hardware decoder
is the yellowish bar in there what's the
scale of the horizontal
that's just the entire benchmark run
there
so uh i forget how long crafty runs over
a couple minutes maybe
so um yeah so
that's just showing the different
different areas so
uh this is just showing
most instructions that are executed in
crafty or not new instructions
you see you see some hardwood
you see some new things early on
uh over time you see fewer things there
is some facial behavior you see that
correlates with our
time spent in the hardware decoder
uh and then there's sort of what happens
with ipc
so there are some small periods where
we're running a little bit
slower because of the hardware decoder
but overall it's uh
you know overall performance converges
very quickly
so which which eyes are those yeah
yes which well yours are theirs okay
eyes
ipc is it arm instructions
or uh we generally measure in arm
instructions per cycle okay if
if if i were to say anything about this
i would say that
i i would probably ignore this because
it's
it's probably some fudge factor uh off
from the real thing
but uh
i i i won't guarantee we get exactly one
ipc on
on crafty but we do do very well there
relative
to other processors so you you can go
and measure it if you want
so if i understand you correctly you
don't block
the original threat while you're
translating uh we
we do our very best not to yes so in a
multi-core system you usually have
some core that is idle uh
so in a two-core you know what what's
the usual utilization of a two-core
system
maybe maybe 1.25
right they're going to be they're going
to be sometimes where you have
highly parallel kernels that that get on
you know two or four or eight cores all
at once
uh if that was a sustained thing then
then you do have to cut in and
and slow one of those cores down
occasionally
in order to be able to produce something
that's much more efficient
but we try to be sensitive about that we
try to look at
uh we we do look very carefully at
things like interrupt latency we have
sub
sub millisecond in our latency on on the
products we've shipped
so do you share translations
yeah do we yes we do yeah
repeat the question sorry the question
was on this video
okay um the last question there was do
we share
translations across processors and the
answer is yes
processes across processes
uh across threads so across threads
within a process we surely do
um across uh processes
there's uh address-based layout
randomization which things
makes things a little bit tricky but the
answer there is also
yes sometimes
did you say sub millisecond interrupt
latency yes
i mean it's that's a knob
you can turn obviously you're trading
off
uh instantaneous or you know like how
how quickly do i get to
uh translating the world and running
fast versus
you know can i afford to delay the user
temporarily right now and so we
we do try not to get in the way
for sustained periods of time and that
means that
we'll there are places where we'll have
to fall back on the hardware decoder if
everything is busy for
longer periods than we might like but in
general people
want their device to be very responsive
right and
and they they care about that more than
they care about the throughput
so uh and we comparatively have forever
to do some of these optimizations right
people don't well
most processes run for some period of
time
uh that gives you enough time to sort of
cut in
and and optimize the important things
so do you run out of translation space
and how do you
decide when you throw up which part and
update it or you have uh
so okay so the question is do we run out
of translation space
it is it is possible
i think in the devices we have shipped
in that hasn't been a
problem but
we certainly are prepared for that
eventuality and and
do garbage collect
so yes if if things are not if things
are not
executed commonly then then
it may be time to get rid of them right
it's that's not a
uh we shipped in a two gigabyte of
memory
uh system that's a tablet
you know that's the only thing we've
publicly announced and that
in in that configuration you don't
you run out you run out of regular
memory long before you run out of
how big is the translation cache uh it's
configurable
so that's the choice of uh whoever we
give the device to so what it is in the
one device
in the one device that's shipped today
it's 128 megs
but that was a knob that
they could have selected different
different settings for
if you don't try to make it
decision which piece of the code is best
optimized
to use and which one to draw out that's
the garbage prediction
last use of listings
we do look at usage as an indication of
what to throw away
for sure so it's expensive to i mean
it's not that expensive but it is
somewhat expensive to form translations
so we are
uh we try to be careful about what we
throw away
uh it's not a full operating system but
but
we do have you know some software there
yes sir so at the other end of the deck
from the dusty deck there's also a very
new program that's trying to take
advantage of the hardware right
um you know intel even has you know 1500
page manuals
on how to optimize on that architecture
do you guys
just provide the armed isa or do you
provide leaky abstractions um
so the question is how do you optimize
for our machine
and i think the answer to that and i
have a slide about that later and for
the most part it's
it's right good code if if you ever get
to the point where it's more than that
then then we can have a discussion but
we
you know like i i think that the
aspirations of most people
about what kind of code they can write
uh
on most machines today is as well beyond
their actual capabilities
i i'm not trying to be arrogant there
i'm just saying
you know we have a team of people who
spent six years thinking about this
machine
and and people come in and say hey i
want to spend like three weeks and make
my code run fast how do i do that
it's you know
odds are there's not a lot they can do
but there are some things they can do
that will help us
so we did have a list of things that
people shouldn't do
uh yeah i mean it's
i think that most of the things that you
well at least in my mind most of the
things are common sense
but but common sense changes right if
you
if other architectures or other
processors give people things for free
they assume that they're free everywhere
then they get upset so so there are
places where we
felt like oh yeah surely nobody will do
this
but but they did so you know
uh what are your units of time for uh
for this benchmark
hey i think what i'm really asking is
how long does it take your jets
so it it how long does it take the jit
to run well
i'm definitely not going to give you to
warm up
oh okay well it's dependent upon your
code footprint right
so so crafty i mean
spec int in general has not large code
footprints compared to
some things we've seen out in the real
world i mean
as an example uh
the most hilarious thing that that we
found well there's a lot of hilarious
things we found but
you know if if you're running your full
screen if you're running your tablet
full screen running a video decoder
uh you're playing this video on on your
tablet and uh
you have dedicated hardware that's doing
all the video decode and all the audio
offload
what's what's your code footprint
two megabytes
so you've answered kind of this obvious
question about you or legit
and how long it takes to warm up but
it's easy to warm up on spec which are
long
benchmarks yeah so what if you want what
what if you're jitting jitted code
because in modern phones there might be
five different types of jitters running
simultaneously
the picture wouldn't seem to be so
pretty how do you do that because the
code being jitted
is probably poor quality arm code to
start with and you don't have much time
to warm up in windows rt for example the
used to reuse rates are extremely low
right not you know millions of
instructions were used at the times you
have inspect but maybe only hundreds of
the time how do you
how do you perform steel doors so i
think that the two examples out there
uh uh that that i would point to
uh for the two extremes of that are uh
sunspider and octane
uh we have the uh
highest arm score on octane
i think of of any any processor out
there
uh and i think we have uh one of the
lower
although not lowest but we have one of
the lower modern sunspire scores
and and sunspider uh runs a sequence of
kernels
for uh milliseconds at a time
and then flushes the entire jit cache as
my understanding
uh in between them uh between iterations
of
that point to critics who would be
concerned about that so that's great
yeah so if
if if your use case looks more like
octane you'd be very happy with us
i know some some people really care
about octane if
if your use case looks like sunspider
which i i really
don't think most people's use case looks
like sun spider but
but that's that's the other place to go
and look
i think and that's in all the published
stuff on the web
so yes sir
so um did your profile did it only
profile branches or do you also do
memory profile
uh yeah yeah we
sorry the question is do we do we
profile
branches and and do we profile uh
memory so i assume by profiling memory
you're looking for
are we going to pay attention to cache
messes and things like that and the
answer is
yes how much
amplification is there due to your
translation
uh that's that depends
i mean i i think you guys had uh
christy uh in a few months ago talked
about risk risk five and and
somebody uh was on him about load
multi-store multi
for uh you know quite a bit of the
presentation
um that's a really dense instruction
right
what's what's the code amplification
from load multi-store multi to
something more reasonable even even on
an arm process
even on a native arm processor right
they don't they don't
execute that as a single up so the
expansion is
is is quite high so it's it's very
it's very dependent on on what your
inputs are
and it'll change as as we go from
microarchitecture to microarchitecture
so i i don't have a really great
answer for you there
so um anyways that
this example just kind of zoomed in a
little bit on three percent of the run
and you can see
see that we you know really quickly and
and sort of monotonically
uh jump up and performance as we
translate more and more of the world
can i disable your transformation
again can i in the operating system
disable those features
uh okay so the question is can you
disable translation
on our processor like if i would just do
that application
sure and i don't want to use your class
why
i mean i i won't say you're the first
person who's asked me that question but
uh uh i mean the answer is yes
accidentally
um but uh you know we're
i i think there's there's a lot of
demand out there again
for i i know i can do a better job in
the three weeks i have to look at your
process or let
give me that right but but
really
i i mean it's it's it's hard i mean i
feel like we have to push back against
against that internally as well as
externally but
but yeah you can disabled out-of-border
machines
uh yeah i mean i i i'm sure there is
some way to an intel and turn
off out of order
because you're afraid of it you know
accidentally
reordering operations which you
care deeply about when they're executed
but
yeah go ahead well those machines have
timers if nothing retired in a certain
amount of time
they they go back and start over right
so right you can think of a similar
the question asking is yeah a bug
right i want to turn it off because it's
got a bug right
uh it's right so so the question is what
what do you do about bugs
i think the answer is we we've already
hidden a lot of bugs from you
so right i mean like
you look at intel's processors they they
have you know 150 errata per chip
and and they have uh the world's best
verification teams i'm sure
uh certainly manpower wise they they
have the most people working on
on these things of anyone so um
actually i have a slide about that um
uh so go ahead and just start one
there's one group of people carol
that's the the hard real time people who
think they count cycles
yes so right hard real time people care
a lot but if you if you're really hard
real time what are you doing executing
on a processor with a cache
right i mean it's like if if you're
truly
a hard hard real time of any sort
uh you don't belong on the kind of
processor that's sold to most people
i was being far more valued if i took a
dusty deck application
i used a modern static compiler all
right
is there a chance i could actually get a
better performance than losing a dynamic
computer
no yeah yeah so
yeah we get that all the time can i
compile directly to the native microcode
and um the answer is no and and even if
you could
you would get lower performance so our
our static compiler
we've run all the same benchmarks
statically compiled to our microcode
versus
using our dynamic uh optimizer and the
dynamic optimizer is faster
because because it's able to use more of
the functionality of the hardware
so so you know could you eventually
get that maybe but but there's a lot of
functionality you'd end up building
exactly our system i think
in the end in order to do that
yes sir uh pardon my skepticism um
every example i've seen of this sort of
thing
presupposes that a huge chunk of real
time is devoted to one task one
benchmark
this sort of thing or a very small
number or a main
benchmark that you're trying to optimize
and some background stuff right
and on my laptop i can check and there's
a thousand tasks running at once
and there seems to be a lot of time but
maybe no one task
gets more than one percent of the cpu so
to what extent does this scale what are
the mechanisms that you use
to do your analysis and optimization and
to what extent
they interfere with each other and to
what extent does the execution of any
one task that you're trying to optimize
a constant versus being influenced
chaotically by the other
900 tasks that are interrupting and
crashing the cache and so forth
clockwise or something where every
millisecond the characters exchange
right so there's a lot of questions
there
let me see if i can start to unpack a
couple of them
um so one of the questions you asked was
hey i run a lot of processes on my pros
on my on my system and
you know are you really going to go and
optimize for all of them well
if if they truly run for small periods
of time maybe not
but i'm guessing that they do run
a lot of shared libraries that they have
in common
and so over time we are going to
optimize for those
uh you know we're going to optimize
those shared libraries so so those tasks
will benefit
um so so you know i think even
you know even even if you have this
system or you have lots of transient
processes
and none of them really run for very
long the
the things that matter on that system
you know like how much time do you spend
in mem copy and memsat
and things like that well that's that's
all going to be there
right how much time do you spend
calling into libraries that do
you know whatever your windowing system
is and things like that i mean it so
there is you know how much time do you
spend in the kernel that all of these
things
get optimized uh
over time so so i think
uh i don't know i haven't i haven't seen
the system where
it's doing something useful and it's
spending no time
executing optimized code but i'm sure
somebody will show it to me sometime and
we'll have some revelation
uh that you had some other questions i'm
not sure if i thought about the first
one didn't get to the rest
um the scalability just
in general in in the process of
recognizing hot spots optimizing hot
spots
to what extent is that at all hardware
dependent and couldn't scale 100 ways
and to what extent is it really just
handled in a uh
an easily scalable software fashion
um i'm not sure that question makes a
lot of sense i'm just saying that's one
of the things that bothers me when i
hear presentations like this
so so our profiling has both hardware
and software components if that's what
you're
just that's the question you're asking
and it is the system get too big
when does the system get too big
well so obviously our tablet is not big
enough no
um i'll clarify yeah shut up
for instance if your system had 12
hardware timers that were being used to
track the most common 12 spots
that would fall apart as soon as you had
more than a handful of processes
if your system had 10 000 hardware
timers that would be better
if your system had no hardware timers
but 10 000 or a million virtual
timers then you wouldn't have a problem
at all
yeah i don't i don't think we drive our
profiling in
in the way that you're thinking of so i
i think
i think the answer is uh yeah we don't
have that particular scalability issue
um but i think that
you know the question you ask about you
know when do you
when would you need to break this up
into multiple systems is a
great one uh we haven't built that or
you know
we we didn't build that system this time
so
you know if if if if i talk about you
know the
500 core machine we were building
whenever we're building it then then
yeah we'll talk about that
so yeah uh were there any other
questions
can you give me a feel for how much
memory bandwidth this consumed
in writing out the translations and
reading them back
is that that's is that a tax or is that
the would you nominate that anyway
so we're running a program which is is
well it's running is going to
steal some memory bandwidth from
from your system that's going to steal
you know we're going to steal some
execution cycles and some memory
bandwidth
but uh is it you know we're gonna steal
some of your cash
cash space as well uh but we do it for a
short period of time
and and you know we
we we try to amortize out to a very
small percentage
of the overall execution time you don't
write it back up you don't write
the optimized code not the main memory
it just stays on the couch that's my
next question
uh the the the cash itself is so
we said earlier we have this 128 meg
cache that's that's main memory backed
so
yeah but you don't flush optimize cut it
out to
the main memory writing over my
carefully written code
the the the space we have
available to us is available to us and
to no one else
so it it was it was never yours to start
with
yeah i can't see it
you you cannot see it you cannot access
it with devices etc etc
yes you seem to get in the optimized
code really quickly
and spend all your time there we try to
uh and so
if you're not spending that much time
kind of with the original
stuff from the hardware translator why
was it worth even including a hardware
translator from arm because
it performs poorly and you don't spend
any time there anyway
couldn't you have provided a simple
software solution to do that because
if there's not any time spent there it
wouldn't have mattered whether you've
done it in hardware software to go back
to your earlier comment about
right and do things in software where it
doesn't matter so
so prior systems did what you're talking
about
they had a 100x penalty for falling off
we shouldn't need that so are there
other cases where your data doesn't look
as good the support
that you would need so so definitely so
so i said earlier
but sunspider we're not that great right
um so there we're leaning heavily on the
hardware decoder
uh there are places where
you know as the previous gentleman
brought up code amplification
that's that can be an issue right so you
have to trade off against that as well
so uh we would prefer to spend
our entire lives in optimized code there
are sometimes reasons that you can't
well maybe paradoxically a simpler
instruction said it's easier to include
the hardware
right sure uh yeah i mean
uh arm is not 100
it's not x86 but it's it's also not
substantially easier than x86
people get surprised when you tell that
to them right but
i mean i'm i'm sure you you've been
there right but but um
okay yeah i mean it's i i think it's uh
yeah it can't be 15 bytes long right
well so
so i i guess history is we did both
it didn't seem like either one was
easier than the other so
that's interesting um
yeah sorry so so yeah i'm kind of i
don't have till 5 30.
keep going okay cool okay then we turn
off the
camera right then the truth comes out i
hope there's alcohol involved
um that's absurd
okay um so uh here's
i just want to give people a quick uh
example from gzip
so we have the c code on the very left
it's a fairly simple loop the inside
of that comparison w equals equals w
size is
almost never executed because i think w
has to get up to hex 8 000 or something
like that
um so the arm instructions that we
select for that translation
are are on the right so essentially what
you can see is we have
a sequence of blocks with branches
connecting them and for the most part
the branch weights are 100 percent or
zero percent to the successors and
predecessors
so uh this is a
little bit of a dummy down version of
our assembly uh this isn't a micro paper
that's gonna
come out in a couple weeks so
uh yeah you can take pictures that's
i've fine it slightly from the
micropaper but it's the same stuff
so um
what we've done we're a transactional
machine
we have two commits in this we've
hoisted some work
out of the loop we've unrolled the loop
uh
we've turned some of the branches into
fault operations because we know that
they're
uh infrequently executed and you know
we're
essentially keeping you know it's all in
your code
we have four integer slots and uh and a
branch slot
and you know we have about four to five
uh
u-ops per bundle here and the result is
about five arm instructions per
cycle a little bit better than that uh
this is
you know i selected this because it
looks good so so you know you're fine to
call me on the marketing side of this
but this is one of the
top 10 uh regions in
this this entire benchmark yeah well the
fair thing to say is how does the agency
know
if this is not uh yeah i could i could
dig that
i could dig up for you how how a15 does
on this but
i i actually john do you know the answer
to that
as well we can dig it up for you after
after the talk yeah yeah okay
we'll we'll get there but yeah we we do
very well on
very nice
so um so anyway so
i i don't know i i don't feel like
there's a whole lot of value to be had
other than taking pictures of this but
just when you said fault
what do you mean but that's a microphone
well so so we have one branch unit
uh and actually this kind of goes back
to there was a question earlier about
um uh gee these jets they emit terrible
code
that they tend to have all kinds of
conditional branches that are never
taken
and so we end up being limited by well
we've only got one branch
to execute per cycle but we know that
almost none of those are real branches
so so we can replace branches with
essentially uh rosin
with asserts right and and because we're
a transactional machine you can just
assert
uh if it's a if it's a 100 one one
direction
as long as you're making that you know
as long as you're right enough of the
time it doesn't hurt you
yeah yeah yeah so so
that's that's a huge huge benefit for us
perspective
uh we're transactional with memory and
registers
so is there something else
well there's all kinds of other stuff
does this happen on the first line of
the code or you
wait for a profile of it uh so we've
we've run that code in the hardware
decoder some number of times we've
picked up the branch profiles
before you decide this is a good
microcode oh you already decided on the
first one we've
picked a number that we like you know in
terms of we've seen this
enough times that we think it's
profitable and worthwhile to
it's not the first round it's few times
whatever the number is
yeah so i mean there's a trade-off to be
had here right between getting it
getting fast code quickly versus
getting the the most optimal code
so so we we do have to make those kinds
of trade-offs
how do you quantity shield processor
uh yeah that's a challenge i mean so so
the question is
how do we do quality assurance on on
this and
and um
we do have uh so
arm obviously gives you architectural
conformance tests which test
you know essentially what what they
think is important
to uh you know
out of the thousands of pages of specs
that they write they produce
tens or hundreds of thousands of tests
and you execute all those tests and
and have to pass all of them uh that's
not
so good for quality assurance on a
machine like this so we have
a lot of our own testing and people
devoted to to that right it's it's a
it's essentially a compiler test
you know we do a lot of directed random
testing essentially
you never run your qa test for much
longer for some optimization to kick in
or you can if if you're inside the
building you can force those
those optimizations to happen more
quickly right
that may not actually explode
it's it's a challenging problem like
like validating any piece of software
it's
there you can think about it for years
and years and write lots and lots of
tests and still find problems right
so here's my question is your errata
sheet bigger or smaller than intel's
errata sheet and some more important
you you you imagine how many they have
how big is your rata list
yeah i mean it's i think
that's i if if the question is how many
bugs have been found outside the
building
yeah in our dynamic code optimization
system
the answer is essentially zero yeah uh
but
if if the question is have we put out
releases of software of our microcode
which
have had uh issues which we have
corrected the answer is
yeah how do you prove that is your
problem versus somebody else's problem
there's no way to prove
whether it happens a it's really
difficult
yeah that's a problem
but i mean because it's something
unusual people tend to point at you
first
but uh but and that is a huge problem
uh but do they point at you correctly
most of the time
no so so like you have to
it's it's difficult to figure out what
kind of teflon you have to wear on any
given day but
yeah but an os like windows
boots up that goes through a lot of the
ls i don't actually own one of these
devices
how would this perform uh through a boot
process like that
um yeah so uh
we've shipped an android device and
i think that our boot time on that
android device
has been uh
essentially as best as we can tell about
the same as all the other android
devices we've shipped
when you talk to the developers there
they don't say that boot time is a high
priority for them because people reboot
their phones
you know if they're having trouble they
reboot their phones
once a day otherwise it's once a week
so um you know
it's it hasn't been a priority it's
clearly
if you look at like linux booting up
right there's a lot of decompression
that it does
uh you know it's actually a substantial
portion of the
of the cycles is you know decompression
and memsa and things like that
but um yeah bringing up all the demons
and things like that i i would imagine
that we lean
more on you know a little bit more on
hardware decoder through some of that
but
but we haven't there's all kinds of
other devices that come into
play there like you know your flash and
so
it's not clear that that's really a a
cpu
speed problem these days although it may
be as flash devices get faster
we'll see
so i i just want to since
i knew you would all be in the audience
uh and a lot
if you're not in the audience you're
probably on my team but um
uh there are a lot of people uh you know
there are a lot of historical bt systems
which we learned from
uh i just wanted to call out a few of
them can you
say something about how you're different
than them
uh so
thank you yeah i
i think
was really the the last major one uh in
in my mind and um you know
amazingly it was you know essentially 10
years ago
so uh since then we've
sorry smile um
thanks so much yeah yeah no i
i i would love i mean if there's anyone
from south machines here i'd love to
hear
them speak about what they're doing um
i it's a little bit hard to tell from
the from
what's on their website um
so what's different this time everybody
has smp we talked earlier about the fact
that we
do our level best to stay out of the way
and it's a lot easier to stay out of the
way if you have an smp machine where one
of the cores is
technically idle or in a low power state
if you can hide that behind people's
back
then you can go off and and do things
and
not have them notice we built a hardware
decoder which eliminates that
101 step down sometimes
we you know hardware has marched on we
have
i think bigger regions that we look at
so it's a part of that is enabled by the
fact that
um you know you you
because you have a hardware decoder and
because
machines are faster now you can go and
work on larger optimization problems and
the things that you find in those
are more profitable
go ahead but so one of the issues
with region size is the the size of the
transaction right
yes how much transaction so is that what
you are living in i would let you have a
bigger
transaction i mean it's it's been 10
years i haven't looked at the numbers
but i'm pretty sure we can build
slightly bigger transactions than 10
years ago and not
not complain about the cost i'm sure you
can too yeah
yeah that is definitely what i'm getting
at yeah transactions are just
simple i
don't really want to talk about the
specifics there
that's a good question um
so yeah i shouldn't talk about that
um so we talked earlier about the skewed
pipeline
uh and you know i think transmeta was
also focused on
energy efficiency but we probably have
more more tools available to us today
than
they did so you know
i hope that answers your question were
there any other things that you wanted
specifics on fx32 one of the big things
is they actually stored
their translations to disk
yes although my my phone doesn't have a
disk right let's look at the same
yeah you don't you don't do that it's
got a bigger disk than most of them
right so
just in case people didn't hear so the
the statement was hey
some of these previous things stored out
translations um
that we hear that about that like
every time we go and talk to someone
about this system
i haven't seen the use case where we
need it
but um and there's there there are huge
problems with doing that from a security
perspective
so we just haven't opened that can of
worms
but um it's it's something that we could
entertain at
some point in a system like this yes sir
of course you do vanilla arms yes
uh the question do we implement neon i
mean that's
that's been mandatory do we optimize
we we do optimize
neon yeah i mean there are limits to
what you can do within uh
with floating point optimizations right
and still have something that's
equivalent
so uh we're we're very careful about
that
and and you know that's another thing
that sometimes people come and suggest
oh can't you just and
no you can't so so we don't do anything
you can't do
one thing we do do that's kind of cool
is for arch 32 we we vectorize the
doubles
but uh so we do have a vectorization
there which is
uh i don't know if that's valuable or
not i've honestly gotten more complaints
about hey
arc64 isn't as fast relative to arch 32
as it is on other
processors and you say oh yeah it's
because we made the arch 32
faster and then that's like not not the
answer they were looking for
so yes yeah i was going to say in terms
of saving translations to disk i mean
android also already does it for you by
pre-pre-compiling
apps in ways so maybe that wouldn't be
as beneficial
so so they're so there they've
so the question was about android l
which has gone from
dalvik to uh oh shoot
art yes where they're pre-compiling the
the java byte code or
pre-jitting it to uh arm
and and spending more time compiling it
um
i guess that's a little bit better
honestly so so we we did
bring up on on both kitkat and
l and and uh l was a little bit more
immature while we were doing bring up
but
uh it it didn't seem to matter to us
much one way or the other
i'm gonna need to get to this guy
eventually but but did you have another
so this is not a big little system right
and that's about all i can say
yes sir for some security applications
you want for example
constant time equality check or
cryptography would
dynamic code optimization open you up to
potentially uh
timing attacks or somewhere because a
lot of those constant
things are optimized up i mean
i i think that falls into sort of the
hard real-time
category where you if you really care
about that you should be
measuring on every system that it's
equivalent in
in every way and then you there's a lot
of paranoia you have to have about
caches and things like that so
definitely we are
uh i we've we've had that brought up to
us and i think i've given the same
answer which is yeah that's
if if you need to go to that extra level
we're not going to stop you
uh but we probably can't help you too
much either like is there a way to turn
off the
vco for a specific code segment is that
even possible
well why don't you come and show me a
case where it matters
and then and then we can work on it
right
i mean that that that's that that's my
answer right is
is like if if you can find a case where
we are
jeopardizing your security in ways that
other processors would not then then we
have something to work on but
until that time it's sort of speculation
you